dans mon lit vraiment avec l'expérience
que j'ai peu ajoute tu peux réagir le
lundi d'une certaine façon de mort d'une
autre façon les mercredis savaria repart
tout
puis jeudi 3 mars à l'hôpital un type
des parts ou encore le magnifique
peut-être tout consommer sait jamais
quand la brigade aujourd'hui sa part aux
sports
[Musique]
reprend les codes bien corps en avant
midi
j'ai essayé de lui donner le plus de
ressources possible le plus de conseils
positif possible qu'en soi aurait de ces
bouts de repiquer une fois excellent
malheureusement c'est sa dernière choc
parce que le cas on va pas entretenues
mais moi il faut que je me dise ce site
cette décision-là faut que je me dis
c'est pas ma décision à moins
[Musique]
une zone cemac réalité c'est notre
quotidien de voir la misère des gens de
voir les crises avons la peine devant la
rage c'est que ça donc oui on est des
échanges mais faut être capable de
tendre l'eponge pour être capable à
recommencer le lendemain